write each of the following in index
form okay so i'm going to write out the
whole thing
and then um we'll do it in index form
okay so here's what we've got
yeah so yeah it's 3 to the power of 2
okay so yeah they're all multiplication
now
this is a good time for me to mention
yeah um okay i'll let you choose
yeah okay and then you can yeah good
good now's a good time to mention that
you've got to be very careful in this
topic more than any other
about how you do your times and how you
do your exes
okay because if you're like me those
look a
lot like x's right so you've got to do
something to make sure you can
distinguish them
okay so here's some options for you okay
you can do an x like that that's okay i
can tell that a part you can do an x
like this you can see it's similar right
but i'm going to say don't do your x's
like that that's just not because that's
that's multiplication okay so don't mix
them up
yeah couldn't you make it like cash i
think capitals are tricky
um the reason why is because you know is
that a capital that there is that a
capital or is that lowercase
it's like well i think size is
two easier thing to mistake so that's
why i think these are soft
uh
now here's what we've got okay
we want this in index form right right
now
this is what's called factor form okay
this is fact
the reason why is because
factors are the things that go together
to make a product and that's that's what
that is
okay so i want to separate all out all
the different bases
okay so for instance two and three
those numbers right you can write that
as two times three separately
right but that's um that's the factors i
just want them all to get so i'm gonna
write that as a six
okay actually so i'm gonna put those
together
okay is that right here
i've got a pair of a's so to be a to the
now let's be um yeah let's be better
let's be more precise
and the power of two or a squared is
fine as well okay
and then b and then you've got three b's
right so b to the power of three
or b cubed there you go
okay so there's index form
there
and there's factor four so you can go
back and forth between the two
okay multiplication
with indices or powers or exponents
whichever you like they're all the same
okay now we did some examples of this
in very simple terms but what we want to
do now um
is be a lot faster at it a little more
automatic okay so for example
let's have a look at one a okay now i
say
simplify first and you get given this
in index form
okay now there's a couple of ways we
could approach this right
we could say let's just write the whole
thing out let's write the whole thing
out of factor form and see what we get
okay so let's try that first all right
this one is three times three there you
go
that's three squared okay
here is what you're looking at okay it's
there but you can look here now it's
fine
and times three times three times okay
yeah so now i've got two threes here now
i've got another four
right one two three
four there you go it's out in fact to
form now
okay but they're all three so i can
count up just like i did before how many
are there in total
i count one two three four five six so i
can rewrite this as
three to the power six
okay ah now there's gotta be a faster
way than this
right like this this here it takes
forever and it'll take even longer
if for example if i make sure you do 3
to the power of 20
so you're have 40. you'd be writing
threes for like five minutes right
and then you have to count them all up
now
how many threes will there be the answer
is
you write 20 here and then you write
another 40 you'll get
60 in total right now before i write
60 where did we get that from what you
did was you
added 20 and 40. you see that
okay now watch this is tricky right
when you multiply
two numbers with the same base but
different indices or different powers
okay you don't multiply the powers you
add the powers you see that
you all told me three to the power of 60
which is which is right
okay you got to watch out for that okay
so i might even write that down over on
the side here
okay uh as an explanation of what we're
doing here and you should do the same
okay when multiplying
uh numbers with the same base
okay it's important that they're both
threes right
like if one of them was a three and one
was a five when you put them together
you don't they don't mix together
do they they're still they're still
threes and fives so if they've got the
same base
right and you multiply them we add
their indices
this fits exactly what we had before i'm
multiplying numbers with the same base
they're all base three same one i chose
earlier
right so in order to get the answer at
the end without writing everything out
like this would be a lot of threes right
all i have to do and this step you
should write it down it's an important
next step to have
is it's three to the power on and now
i'm going to
add up all the indices add them right so
it'll be ten
there's one three and five
you add up all of them together okay
so ten plus three plus five is eighteen
three to the power of t got it done